so if you've been sick you know that
intensive care is not something that
doctors recommend lightly Boris Johnson
is clearly in danger tonight and that's
a bad sign Johnson is in his mid-50s and
hale enough to lead a country if this
can happen to him a lot of us should be
worried and we are worried worried
enough to endure things that just a
month ago would have seemed preposterous
last week dr. Michael Ryan he's a leader
at the World Health Organization
announced that in response to the spread
of this virus authorities may have to
enter people's homes and remove family
members presumably by force in most
parts of the world the Jew to lock down
most of the transmission that's actually
happening in many countries now is
happening in the household at family
level in some senses transmission has
been taken off the streets and pushed
back into family units now we need to go
and look in families to find those
people who may be sick and remove them
and isolate them in a safe and dignified
manner just so you know we're coming to
your house seizing your children and
quote isolating them in a safe and
dignified manner whatever that means now
that's not something that under normal
circumstances official officials
casually drop during briefings it's the
kind of statement that might trigger
violence people don't respond well when
you threaten to take their kids but Ryan
said it like it was no big deal
and that's how the media treated it his
threat didn't make headlines in any of
the major newspapers in this country
that's the kind of moment we're in so
how long will this moment last well on
Friday Eric Garcetti the mayor of Los
Angeles predicted that the first in a
series of lock downs will go on until
June one of the things that just
concerns me it's not one of those
immediate concerns but it is you know
this draws out through the summer and
then then the cold weather comes around
and then there's another wave of it how
do you as a leader how do you think
about this early on when people said is
this just going to be a few days or a
couple weeks I said no I think it's at
least two months and I said if we're
successful in this we can expect a
second spike in the late fall or early
winter that's how viruses work we've
been
steal ourselves for a second and maybe
even third round of this but we also
need to be nimble enough to know we're
not gonna flip a switch one day and turn
the economy back on a quote second and
maybe even third round of lockdowns
that's a long time
former Obama official Jason Furman who's
now an economist at Harvard predicts the
disruption may be even more severe than
that quote we should certainly be
prepared for a meaningful level of
deliberate suspension of economic
activity for the rest of the year will
it be nice to that there's a good reason
for all of this of course everyone wants
there to be a good reason sincerely yet
the arguments for a prolonged national
lockdown are starting to sound strained
in a much discussed article on medium
recently to academics from Pittsburgh
argued that lifting the lockdown at all
even many months from now would be
negligent quote as long as a large
majority the population remains
uninfected lifting containment measures
will lead to an epidemic almost as large
as would happen without having
mitigations in place at all well that
sounds plausible when you read it in
fact it sounds like science but is it
science a large majority of the
population remains uninfected they say
but is that true
we don't know it's true as it say nobody
can say what percentage of the American
population is infected or has been
infected
there haven't been large-scale
randomized test conducted here we don't
even know when the disease first arrived
in the United States there's informed
speculation that this strain of kroehner
virus has been here since late November
or December authorities traced the first
confirmed case to January 15th in
Washington State an unnamed 35 year old
Chinese immigrant landed the United
States after visiting his family in
Wuhan and wound up in a hospital outside
Seattle
apparently he recovered now depending on
how you count the virus has been
circulating among us for up to four
months now for most of that time there
was no systematic attempt to quarantine
the population how many Americans were
infected over that period again we don't
even have a ballpark number for that but
the number could be enormous because the
virus turns out to be much easier to
transmit than we thought it was on
Friday you may have noticed the CDC
issued new guidance on masks use the
government now recommends wearing quote
cloth face coverings in public
why'd they make that change because
researchers are learning more about how
this virus moves from person to person
scientists now believe the krona virus
can be transmitted by someone who shows
no symptoms merely by speaking remember
when they told you that hand-washing was
the key to staying safe that
recommendation was based on the belief
the virus lived mostly on surfaces and
that's not the case we're still not
exactly sure how the virus is spread but
among some populations and this is
interesting to know it appears to be
astonishingly widespread an article in
the Italian media last Thursday for
example described a blood drive in a
village in a lumber tea that's in the
northern part the most infected part of
the country of the 60 people who showed
up to give blood 40 tested positive for
coronavirus none had shown symptoms of
it none knew they had it keep in mind
that Lombardi has been strictly locked
down by government order since March 9th
that's almost a month ago yet about 70%
of this group got it anyway a report
from Hong Kong in February suggested
that a woman diagnosed with the krona
virus may have infected others 10 floors
away in the same apartment building even
though she never came into contact with
any of them
health officials concluded the virus
likely traveled through plumbing pipes
to different apartments and it wasn't a
wild guess in 2003 an outbreak of SARS
spread the same way so it's starting to
look like the corona virus is more
transmissible than we expected or we're
told the good news is it also seems far
less lethal overall people are still
dying in large numbers not all of them
are sick or old and that's terrifying to
watch but as the data trickle in there's
evidence that many infected people are
not sick
Iceland has tested a larger percentage
of its population than any country in
the world they test about five percent
of all citizens the United States by
comparison has tested point three
percent so far about half those who've
tested positive in Iceland have been
completely asymptomatic so given all of
this what is a wise response to this
pandemic historically health officials
have used quarantines to contain
infectious diseases until now a
quarantine consisted of separating the
sick from the general population and
then doing everything possible to
protect the especially vulnerable in
this case that would include the elderly
and the immunosuppressed
other groups we have a pretty good idea
that targeted quarantines work they've
been used for centuries around the world
but that's not what we did instead the
United States and many other countries
instituted mass quarantines in which
government shut down entire nations for
long periods that's never happened
before
now mass quarantine makes sense if
you're fairly certain it will prevent
mass infection but are we certain of
that well despite what you might hear on
television we are not certain of that
still in fact there are some indications
it hasn't been as effective as we'd
hoped it would be
Italy imposed for the toughest lockdowns
in Europe almost a month later as we
just told you an overwhelming majority
of at least one town has been infected
with the virus anyway now it's possible
to imagine that a mass quarantine might
stop transmission of a virus it might
work if it actually separated people if
citizens were forced to stay in their
homes and not have any interaction with
other people but we're not doing that in
the United States we never will do that
here too many Americans live alone for
one thing people would starve to death
instead the directive we're living under
is this stay home except to buy food the
one place you can go is the supermarket
where by the way everyone else in your
neighborhood has been this week from an
epidemiological standpoint this is
lunacy if you wanted to infect an entire
population you'd encourage everyone in a
specific zip code to meet regularly in
one enclosed location it doesn't make
sense
authorities must know it doesn't make
sense that's obvious but instead of
changing course or fine-tuning they're
doubling down hoping that vehemence will
compensate for bad science here's the
mayor of Los Angeles just last week if
you've observed recurring violations of
the safer at home order please continue
to let us know at coronavirus LA City
org slash business violation you know
the old expression about snitches well
in this case snitches get rewards we
want to thank you for turning folks in
and making sure we are all safe so you
just saw the mayor of our second-biggest
city offering to pay citizens to snitch
on their neighbors for among other
things daring to go to work working is
one activity we've decided should not be
allowed jogging fishing
fine being employed a massive threat to
public health we've decided that offices
are somehow more dangerous than
supermarkets far more dangerous though
no one has to date bothered to explain
how the result of this by some estimates
more than 17 million Americans are
unemployed right now that's the highest
number in the history of this country
a year from now and we should think
about this how will all of us feel about
the decisions we've made in the face of
this pandemic is there a single person
who sincerely expects that coronavirus
itself will hurt more people in the end
than the damage we're causing in our
response to it probably not mass
unemployment is almost certain to cause
far more harm including physical harm to
the average family than this disease in
1967 to psychiatric researchers decided
to rank traumatic life events in order
of how profoundly they affected people's
health stress can kill you we know that
and they wanted to determine which kinds
of stress were the most dangerous the
doctors found that losing a job ranked
high on the list of health degrading
traumas joblessness came in well above
death of a close friend to put it in
some perspective if you ever found
yourself unemployed with dependents to
take care of you understand this
unfortunately many of our policymakers
don't understand they've never been in
that position
they never will be our professional
class doesn't have much interest in
middle-class job loss or its
consequences we know that because
they've essentially ignored it for
decades not to mention the family
disintegration and the drug epidemics it
has spawned so far about 10,000
Americans have died from the wuhan
corona virus that number will rise and
it will likely include people you know
that's a tragedy but it's not the only
tragedy in progress in this country in
2018 more than 67 thousand Americans
died of drug overdoses the year before
more than 70,000 died that's more than
the entire population of the towns most
of us grew up in and those totals are
far lower than the real number according
to people who study the question the
drug epidemic has permanently changed
the demographics of this country but for
some reason cNN has not kept a running
tally of drug casualties on the screen
why is that well you know why it's not
their peer group it doesn't seem real
they're not that interested and the same
thing is going on now
if the coronavirus shutdown was crushing
college administrators or nonprofit
executives or green energy lobbyists it
would have ended last week instead it's
mainly service workers and small
business owners who have been hurt and
they're not on television talking about
what they're going through you need to
look closely to see their suffering over
the weekend the head of Indiana's Family
and Social Services Administration
announced that calls to the state's
mental health and suicide prevention
hotline had gone from about a thousand
to twenty five thousand a day calls to
Indiana's addiction hotlines have risen
dramatically as well reports of domestic
violence have spiked in this country and
in fact around the world in France they
rose thirty-two percent in a single week
some day we'll get the numbers on the
child abuse going on during this
lockdown and we'll all feel sick to our
stomachs once again coronavirus is not
the only bad thing that's happening in
America right now horrifying as it is we
should never minimize the danger of this
pandemic or minimize our obligation to
respond to it wisely we've been saying
that on this show for months
no thoughtful person wants to reopen
baseball stadiums tomorrow we're booked
a cruise to Shanghai but there has to be
a more balanced course than the one we
were on now for most people going to
work cannot be more dangerous than
buying produce at Safeway toys a week
and if it is more dangerous tell it tell
us how it is more dangerous and be
specific when you describe that
otherwise it's time to start caring
about the entire population healthy
people are suffering badly too